you're trying to achieve what hunting
stands for but at
a much larger scale which is what kind
of bill campos stands for
but what what are your thoughts on
hunting as a source of meat it's amazing
100 pro hunting um i think
the reason that hunting flips a switch
for so many people
is because it's the first time they've
had clean meat
in their lives wow okay so i think that
the hunter's journey
when people get so turned on by hunting
they're just like oh my god
i'm never going back yeah i'm saying
that's great if you've got access to
that if you know the guy who'll give you
the backstrap awesome
but like you that's not very that's not
achievable for most of us
yes um and i do think that talking to
hunters about their experiences what
they love about it
many of them are just outdoors and i say
that because most of them are men but
most
love the outdoors aspect of it and being
out in in the wild
but a lot of them it's because of how
they feel when they eat the meat
and it's because they're eating i mean
99 of meat in america is made in a very
specific way
and it's in in a way that is pretty
inflammatory
not incredibly delicious and when you're
on that extreme
um and then you toggle to having this
totally different style of product
it feels radically different in your
body so of course you're like i'll never
go back
so when i talk about us being on that
spectrum it's like well it's
hunted me i mean i can never on any
commercial operation create the variety
of
the biodiversity of species that an elk
gets when it's
wandering around of a zone i mean i can
there's no way you can do that on a farm
so there's always going to be
that extra 5 or 10 that those wild
animals are going to have
you know and those wild animals also
fast for longer as they go through
periods of starvation
and that creates an even like slower
growth for musculature that's going to
be create even more
unique flavor and characteristics and so
that's why there's that
that extra in the hunted meat but you
can come a lot closer
with regenerative traditional farming to
that flavor and health
um than with any other type of farming i
know so that's where i see it on the
spectrum i love that people are
getting excited about about game because
it's all it's better for your health
it's got all the same characteristics as
regeneratively farmed meat
and it gets people turned on to like
simple delicious food
you know you shouldn't have to cover
food with sauce that's got corn syrup
and soy
a bunch of junk in it to make it
palatable if you got to put sauce on
your food you need to look at your
ingredients
you need to revisit what you're starting
from because if you have to
put a bunch of things to mask flavor
onto anything you're eating
you're trying to basically fool your
palate into doing what's not best for
your body
we're trying to to tell our palettes
like just make it through this plate so
you can get the calories in
and we're masking the fact that we don't
actually find it very appetizing
so we're kind of teaching ourselves to
overcome our instinct
with food we're saying here's this kind
of
bland based substrate not very
interesting i'm not like sparking to it
awesome put sugar and salt on it just up
the hyper process flavor profile
great done and then your spark to it
yeah that's not that's a very short road
and that's i think
a lot of the health problems we have now
is because we're
masking flavors and basically trying to
get ourselves to move down this path of
the same way we behave around all hyper
processed foods
yeah and that gets us into a mess with
our health so if we can get
things like game where people love the
flavor out of the gate but it's natural
simple mentally processed like that's a
win
yeah that it reverses that
hypoprocessing
trend that we're on as a human species
and that's uh that's the promise of
regenerative farming that's the promise
of hunting
obviously the former can be scaled the
hunting
i think cannot be scaled right but in
many ways the hunting
inspires the world that this is the
right way to eat yes
and and that naturally leads to then
uh the humane farming regenerative
farming idea
which is this idea that hunting
represents
how do you scale that well if you look
at like you know we're talking about
people use this sort of marketing
language of like happy cows or
that kind of thing you know if you're
talking about the happiest animals it's
wild animals right
so if you wonder why these practices are
good
talk to hunters you know you're talking
about animals that have lived in their
evolutionary capacity right who have
played their role in the ecosystem
who've
lived their meaning of life right and
that's
a very powerfully different kind of role
than
than livestock production so i think if
we can make our livestock production
as similar to wild as possible then
we're
a lot of steps closer
you